España condena por primera vez el golpe
militar de 1936 y los cerca de 40 años
de Dictadura franquista lo hace con la
nueva ley de memoria democrática que
sustituye y amplía la aprobada en 2007
conocida como ley de memoria histórica
además de la condena la nueva Norma
redefine el concepto de víctima toda
persona que haya sufrido individual O
colectivamente daño físico moral o
psicológico daños patrimoniales o
menoscabo sustancial de sus derechos
fundamentales como consecuencia del
franquismo
se creará también un registro y censo de
víctimas y se declararán ilegales los
tribunales franquistas de excepción así
como sus sentencias el estado ASUME el
liderazgo en la búsqueda activa de
personas desaparecidas se calcula que
todavía hay 114.000 en paradero
desconocido y se impulsará un Banco
Nacional de ADN se dará acceso libre
gratuito y universal a todos los
documentos del franquismo y habrá una
comisión de investigación para conocer
si se cometieron vulneraciones de
Derechos Humanos entre 1978 y 1983 en
plena transición se renombrará el
mausoleo franquista del Valle de los
caídos por Valle de cuelgamuros pasarán
a ser centros de memoria cárceles y
lugares de tortura y se obligará a
retirar vestigios franquistas en
educación la asignatura de historia dará
a conocer la represión sufrida En
aquellos años y por primera vez se
pondrá especial foco en la figura de la
mujer con reconocimiento pero también
con reparación para madres compañeras o
familiares de víctimas
Francisco Franco dio un golpe de estado
en 1936 al gobierno democrático
republicano inició una guerra civil en
la que murieron más de 500.000 personas
El golpe triunfo en 1939 y empezó una
dictadura de tintes fascistas Y
ultracatólicos desde ese momento se
emprendió una represión contra todo
oposición hasta la muerte en 1975 del
dictador